he pulls a flash point and goes back in
time and we end up connecting Justice
League batfleck with Robert Pattinson
the Batman is being developed right now
our side wins earth destroyed but like
the team grows Justice League 2 will be
a team-up between the Green Lantern
Corps the Justice League
battling Darkseid and his army theory
and folks the Justice League Snyder cut
is real dark sites come in and that
might even open a boom tube to a Justice
League sequel even if it takes another
hashtag movement to get what we want
I'm Erik Bosse going rogue remotely with
me today are Sam basher hello hello
welcome back Tommy Bechtold thrilled to
be here I believe you I think and
Huddleston welcome back pop of Oz i
crack a bang energy yeah you have to
finish that by the end of the episode
well no well tell by your pupil dilation
all right on this episode we are talking
about our friendly neighborhood Snyder
man Oscar producer Zaki wrote that pun
didn't meet yeah next nighter confirmed
last week that HBO max will release his
recut of Justice League and it's coming
in 2021 and it sounds like Snyder's
vision might be structured as like a six
episode miniseries I actually went into
what those episodes might be in
yesterday's video go check it out if you
haven't already but here let's discuss
the way the Snyder cut plan to set up
the DC EU so there's this alternate
ending of Steppenwolf severed head
rolling to the feet of Darkseid there
were these rumors of that cryptic
nightmare sequence from Batman V
Superman getting more of a focus with
that dark injustice Superman and there
was a rumor of like a possible Green
Lantern Corps post-credits scene
now there currently aren't plans for a
Justice League sequel beyond this Snyder
cut on HBO max but if this series is a
huge hit yeah that could definitely be
enough for these loose ends to reawaken
Snyder's own vision for the DC you and
Justice League - so I want you guys to
me what Snyder's Justice League too
could look like alright I'll go first
and I'm very excited because I've kind
of had to co-opt a pitch that I've had
for a while now I think it will work
here pretty well so now one of the
rumors that has been circulating that
that we were supposed to see the death
of a certain Batman at the end of
Justice League Two which is crazy it's
bonkers I don't know how that would have
all fit maybe they would have done
something Grant Morrison nee from the
comics but that doesn't matter right now
I also want to touch upon the time
travel Easter egg that we got from the
first film that didn't pay off and
Justice League whatsoever as far as I
could tell so my pitch is that in an
extended Justice League to building off
of what could be in the Snyder cut we
see Bruce died and Barry's destroy it's
his best buddy Bruce he's the first
person to ever talk to him about having
superpowers this means a lot to him so
he pulls a flashpoint and goes back in
time and we end up connecting Justice
League batfleck who is now out of a
contract doesn't want to do Batman
anymore with Robert Pattinson the Batman
that's being developed right now so he's
talking to Batman we don't even really
need to acknowledge the fact that those
are two different people right now it's
just a younger Bruce and I think a way
to kind of connect it a little bit is
that we use Robert Benson name we we
take him from the past to the future and
use this younger more youthful more
inexperienced Batman to have a more
creative solution to dealing with this
alien threat and so at the end of the
movie he survives people learn from what
his predecessor did we were like hey we
don't kill people that's not what
Bettman's do that's not what we're all
about we see Robert Pattinson Batman go
back to his present day with the
knowledge of like Darkseid and I also
want to throw out there we should deal
with the nightmare future vision that
the other batfleck have so maybe that's
what's going on right now but now Robert
Pattinson this Batman has seen this and
at a younger age decides to look out for
metahumans for Superman's and other
super-powered superheroes to bring
together and form the Justice League at
an earlier date while also using the
cash that we already have that is signed
on the people that
the kid the a cast that people already
like so we have like ray Fisher cyborg
we have Jason Momoa as Aquaman we have
gal gadot's Wonder Woman and and even
more and I think this could in a way fix
some of the problems with that movie
Superman and the other Justice League
film without deleting them because they
were still important to getting to this
point but were able to tell a new fresh
story with a with the same Justice
League basically but with a I don't want
to say optimistic because I feel like
that was a naughty word for the DC EU
but with a different tone and also this
is a way to do flashpoint without
totally nuking Barry's character because
I know he goes back in time to save his
mom but by doing that he like creates
World War 3 and almost kills billions
and trillions of people all across the
universe so in this case he just says
Batman and it puts him right back and we
never have to deal with any time-travel
ramifications I love it
Sam can I ask a clarifying question if I
may
are you saying that through the like a
flashpoint type style event Robert
Pattinson is like an alternate past like
alternate timeline version of batfleck
or is like Robert Pattinson just what
Ben Affleck looks like when he was like
20 years young I like the idea that this
is just what Bruce Wayne looks like now
after like the Joker the death of Robin
or something and like I said it comes to
flashpoint like we could kind of explore
the speedforce we explored time travel
and without nuking Barry's character
look we could set up Wally West if we
want to for future movies boat let's not
totally ruin Barry Allen's the flash I
agree I love that idea Sam and I love I
think that to me is the big unanswered
question from Snyder's DCU is just that
that time vortex sequence like if you
could just give me something to like
rationalize that or make it more
complicated
I still as much the mixed feelings I
have about some of those movies that's
one where I'm like ooh give me more of
that time for change it Sam I'm gonna
award you two Rogi Sparkle bucks
Wow thank you it looks like it's coming
out over here what do we have
oh look it's a unicorn USB light nice
come from that's pretty nice oh wait we
have another one coming in let's do this
IKEA this when you're walking around
I've definitely passed by dozens of
those in the lower levels
I miss IKEA so bad I can't wait to go
back
what's the Swedish word for our glass
[Music]
thank you for the assist
all right I'll go next I'll go next
believe the hype I'm like Kermit the
Frog Justice League car - it's gonna be
easy being green all right it's all
about those goddamn lanterns baby Green
Lantern the scene is set first of all
Zack Snyder has mentioned recently that
there is a cameo in his cut of Justice
League that would bring a familiar face
back to the DC Cinematic Universe who
liked that tweet none other than mr.
Ryan Reynolds Hal Jordan himself so I've
connected the dots and I believe that
there would be a post-credit scene don't
laugh at me I'm going featuring el
Jordan maybe some other Green Lantern
Corps members as well setting in the
stage for a galactic an intergalactic
space battle at the beginning of Justice
League 2 that will then make its way to
earth and fight there will be a team-up
between the Justice League and the Green
Lantern Corps why do I think this is
going to happen because a little birdie
told me on the internet that Kevin Feige
is having trouble getting the Deadpool 3
movie off the ground because he's not an
individual fan of the character it was
as it was not a Marvel Studios homegrown
product so that movie is currently
stalled Rob Liefeld says it's never
gonna be made now he said insane things
on the internet before it also doesn't
Orhan's so and you trust him I don't
know I don't know if you could trust him
but to me the seeds have been planted
the water is coming down from the
there to grow the green lantern played
by Ryan Reynolds in the DC Cinematic
Universe once more things are gonna get
dark as in Darkseid battling the Green
Lantern Corps at the beginning of the
movie and then I believe the fight will
move down to earth
Justice League 2 will be a team-up
between the Green Lantern Corps the
Justice League
battling Darkseid and his army of
handsome handsome aliens and what I just
have to follow up here what is dark
sides agenda here is it the the T's of
the whole anti-life equation that we got
in the nightmare sequence is he just
trying to pick up in the mother box
quest that step and what was doing what
what's his endgame well I believe that
we will have to follow the linear
pattern of picking up on Steppenwolf's
Feld question he'll be he'll be suing
that goal just because it has to tie in
listen my idea is bulletproof and
fantastic but it does follow that's some
logic so with that I will concede that
we will unfortunately have to remember
that Steppenwolf was a character in
these movies and and was trying to
accomplish a task which he failed at and
we felt him we fail to meet me help
we felt the Antarian Hinds we felt
everyone failed each other there there's
no one to really blame except for to
look in the mirror and blame yourself
because we all fail Tommy I love the
Green Lantern Corps I am death like I'm
bummed that Geoff Johns thing seems to
have stalled out at the moment and I
wish that like the 2011 Ryan Reynolds
you know what I kind of think in your
version and your head Canon Tommy Ryan
Reynolds when he plays a failed version
of a superhero he's always given a
second chance is there any person on
earth is there any actor that has the
juice to get himself back in as a
character that was so maligned and such
a failure like we will forgive Ryan
Reynolds for anything ant as what if he
got Hugh Jackman to play another member
of the Green Lantern Corps the Jackman
huh from the x-men movies we get a
mentor Corps Tommy I love your
enthusiasm
so I'm going to give you a green Sparkle
buck but it'll just be one because
you're kind of given some part to of a
rogue theory episode energy to a part
one still get one because there's a lot
in your theory that I really love and I
would love to see I fully accept and
that sparkle buck has turned into the
Adventures of Pinocchio VHS starring
Jonathan Taylor Thomas and Martin Landau
this is a hologram cover disappear that
each jtt that he's a puppet gorgeous jtt
puppet as you could see transformations
much like these films are beginning to
transform
why does Martin Landau he plays Geppetto
why is he turning into the boy I don't
know I think I'm gonna guess as is the
answer to most why did things happen in
Hollywood cocaine the artist designing
the cover stayed up for 72 hours and in
the end he concluded that it was a
father son Holy Spirit dynamic - a
puppet boy and father and that's how we
got this unholy trinity right here for
for that wonderful explanation of the
hologram technology on the Pinocchio
live-action you get a second bonus for
that that's incredible it's a non
holographic VHS of the Goonies Oh dizzy
adventure with cloud crowd-pleasing fun
says Kathleen Carroll of the New York
Daily News we we know Goonies listen
guys I don't want to list some of the
star power but if you heard of Thanos
because Josh Brolin is in this handy
have you heard of Samwise Gamgee Sean
Astin is in the movie have you been
represented by an entertainment lawyer
that you said jeez that looks like chunk
all grown up he's in the movie practices
Entertainment Law in Holly
that is so wonderful to learn he had it
passed I think of all of them all right
Zach it is your turn
and so it's what you got um okay so
basically his original vision was for
Justice League to an unfold a lot like
with the second and third one being a
lot like infinity war an endgame
basically the second Justice League
movie ends with like darks dark side
winning destroying the world right
getting like to the nightmare situation
like Sam proposed right and then in the
third one for some time travel and
traveling to and from apocalypse and new
Genesis and all this kind of
interplanetary boom tubing right they're
able to do their big end game fight and
I think something along those lines will
still happen I think that whatever the
version of Justice League to is it will
involve like them losing and I think
like because part of the problem with
the first Justice League movie why
people were dissatisfied maybe part of
the reason we want that just the Snyder
cut is because like it ended like in a
very traditional way we're like the good
guys teamed up to beat the bad guy he's
dead forever and here we go right and it
didn't feel like oh we're setting up I
can't wait to come back for future
movies if anything it's like I can't
wait to maybe see this Aquaman movie cuz
right Jason Momoa seems pretty fun or
whatever and so I think like that's what
we need we need our Empire Strikes Back
we need our infinity war right we need
to see a villain that is capable not
only being a threat to all these heroes
but like is better than them right
they're gonna need to improve to recruit
more to do whatever to overcome this bad
force of darkside right who is like the
DC the DC Universe is Thanos in every
way right like vanos was pretty much a
ripoff of Darkseid right and like and
because he's coming after Thanos they
have to figure out a way to make him
better
right cuz like nobody's gonna put up
with a pale imitation of vanos right
it's just a little less purple it's like
you have to make him harder tougher
bigger badder so I think he needs to win
in like really in kind of the original
proposed plan which I think works really
well for this like he does and he wins
in a way that's even worse than the way
Santos won right he wins by like just
wiping out earth not taking off half the
people so they can go to support groups
and like admire the new whales and
Harbor or whenever right like he wins
the earth is destroyed like everything's
a desert Batman has to wear khaki trench
coats like it's bad it's a really dark
reality right yeah
fans have Banana Republic truly win but
I so I think that's that's where we're
going and now again that was his
original vision
I think the way things will be shifted
is because Justice League I think now a
second Justice League needs to come
after we know what's coming after Wonder
Woman 1984 and the second Aquaman
definitely and it'll be after the Batman
right which I don't think will intersect
with this with the jl timeline here but
i think like we need a Green Lantern
core movie first we need maybe a cyborg
spin-off movie right maybe even
something like a third Wonder Woman
movie something like that like we need
where maybe we get introduced to some
more tertiary characters the reason
endgame works so great is cuz man when
those portals open up and you recognize
like 50 faces right and like that's so
great in like none of those faces were
new to endgame right they'd all come
from like a bunch of movies I think like
that was a tough part about Justice
League to say first time we're meeting
flash really first time we're meeting
cyborg like we hadn't spent a lot of
time with batfleck right there's still
like a lot to be introduced in that
movie so like we need to do a lot more
introducing so that can pay off in
Justice League to still I want to see
like a much bigger Justice League team
still get defeated by Darkseid knowing
that they're gonna have to regroup for
whatever that third movie is so that's
that's my pitch for it dark side winds
earth destroyed but like the team grows
the team gets like more of a character
arc we get to get a lot more background
information which some of that has been
hinted we will get in the Snyder
Cutright a lot more cyborg backstory a
little bit more flashback story we need
to flesh out these characters so that it
just devastates us when they lose yeah
yeah I like that idea Zack I'm gonna
award you one Rogge because I do
completely agree structurally with what
this story would have to be we
need a really really dark story to
follow so I'm where'd a new one and the
reason it's not more is I as I'm like
Marvel handled the big battlefield you
know like endgame gave me everything I
needed I want to see exactly how DC
makes darkside different from Thanos I
wanted like already we're gained a sense
of like there's a post-apocalyptic
wasteland with a big ol Magus temple
uh-huh in the dunes and like I want to
see what led to that and I don't know if
I need an on your left moment you know
like maybe there is a version of that
that could work but I feel like too many
haters such as CEO and game did it you
know there's something there but you are
totally on to something that Darkseid
has potential to be so much darker even
than Thanos and and could be an even
more gripping villain that were truly
afraid of as to as opposed to like this
weird holy man that we kind of follow in
his quest to sacrifice his daughter no
but I I'd love that idea and I've loved
all these ideas I want to hear the back
in a tweet okay first off I didn't get
to except my Sparkle but oh yes yes yes
our exhaust how dare you I mean it's bad
enough you shortchange me in pay out it
is a screener version of Logan okay
somebody's fiance was in Sag in 2016 for
dues paid on time
alright give it back to me in a tweet
okay I'll go and I'm hate to dis
disappoint my fans but I'm gonna push
you away from the rhyming scheme and
it's going to be my plans and then it's
going to be a beautiful new Green
Lantern core cast of hot young diverse
actors and then it's gonna say 2020 and
it's gonna be Ryan Reynolds in that
terrible CGI Hal Jordan soon because
Green Lantern Corps movie I believe was
supposed to come out June 6 2020 in the
original really so we have
we'd have a gorgeous like zendaya Green
Lantern Corps Ana de Armas in the Green
Lantern Cole Sprouse the Cole square out
screen my Harry Styles screen that
record but instead we're getting the guy
from waiting in his CGI Green Lantern
Green Lantern costume that's what 2020
is to me that what we oh I'll go flash
Benson it's easy peasy but then have the
gift of the flash and Superman racing
but edited so Robert Pattinson face from
Twilight's like less vampires looking
over at Mary
while Barry's Quetta today look over
them and they're kind of giving each
other little bestfriend eyes like that
okay and mine is I will pick up the
gauntlet that Tommy dropped on his way
to history and Justice League to the
Snider cut is your friend
did you like infinity war let's do it
again we're getting the Ryman there's
Achatz of mothers I'm proud of you that
turned into a screener of Paul Thomas
Anderson's fans another great movie from
that same year something woodcock yeah
so we don't let us know in the comments
that I'm sure they won't comment about
my physical appearance will do anyway
let us anyway well if you're concerned
about your physical appearance whether
it's on your face or under your pants we
want to help you out with our sponsor
today's episode Manske manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels these guys spent eighteen
months designing the lawnmower 3.0 it's
the greatest ball hair trimmer the world
has ever seen or the world will never
see cuz those pubes are staying nice and
tucked in your choice
sun's out puns out write my mind you
thought that it just tucked the pubes
instead of shaking just jab fold to your
pubes at a 90-degree angle at the base
it's like some back up you shaved is the
pube tux
this thing is waterproof it has a 90
minute battery so if it takes you to
shave you and your friends boy you don't
even need the to do it during the
daylight because guys it's got an LED
light so you see what you're doing right
it's you know you're like if you're a
coal miner and if you're trapped in the
coal mine good thing you got your pube
trimmer with you cuz man escapes got you
covered
manscaping accents are a thing in the
past thanks to man escapes patented skin
safe technology we've also got quiet
stroke check on their 7000 rpm trimmer
and odor 7000 of something is going in
to keeping your nuts nice and shaved
that's exciting
get 20% off your order and free shipping
with the code rogue theory at manscaped
comm that's 20% off and free shipping at
manscaped commie use the promo code
Rogan theory make sure to smell rogue
correctly or OG you eat not Rouge don't
ruin your Labor Day picnics with too
much pubic hair this year guys you're
obligated to shave your pants no videos
three months earlier than your fingers
watch today yeah like every day I'm just
trying to keep people safe
waiting for the whole summer
yeah I get a lot of wrong views are the
ones that I'm in people washable all
right folks every week we play a game of
rogue theory with our patrons on new
rock stars discord this week we had a
few patrons pitched their plot ideas for
Christopher Nolan's tenet film based on
the latest trailer that I broke down
earlier this week be sure to check that
out I think I think I figured it out I
don't fully understand physics anyway
there's a lot of great ideas that were
pitched there's a great theory from
every rose
every rules with a pretty insane theory
they push that John David Washington's
character it's gonna have to reset the
Big Bang to make sure the universe does
it become pure chaos
we love that idea but the winner was our
man Danny X with his pretty plausible
thought that actually included Robert
Pattinson scare achter being a mole in
the tenant organization and shot David
Washington's character has to sacrifice
himself by jumping into another timeline
to stop like another world war it seems
it like oh this actually makes sense and
any theory that you pitched on Tennant
it's going to be a rogue theory because
that movie seems to be like the rogue
Asst crazy wild ride I've ever seen what
do you guys think of this I love it
I'm so confused by it I can't wait to
see it I don't know what it's about I
won't understand when I watch it I won't
understand ten years later after
watching you break it down I won't ever
understand the movie and I will be there
opening night and I will be there again
three more times and I will keep
rewinding time it still won't understand
it I'm excited for Tennant in the same
way like with inception and interstellar
christopher nolan does a great job of
like creating insane whatever
technologies or methods or whatever but
then like using them to tell like a good
story that like tugs at the heartstrings
and i think like i think he's gonna be
able to do that lieutenant - absolutely
anyone watching you could play - and
have your theory read on an episode of
rogue theory just like these guys have
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash new rockstars and you can join our
discord it's a great way to help keep
this channel alive during these
difficult times because you know we're
all shooting stuff from home it ain't
easy we're getting through it thanks to
the help from our friends in our patreon
community all right let's move on to our
next topic guys so just Whedon and Zack
Snyder had become these central figures
to the whole Snyder cut debate and in
the general comic book movie world after
this whole thing went down
each of them have respectively shaped
the MCU in the DC EU now
Joss Whedon stepped in to finish Justice
League after Snyder had to leave it due
to a family tragedy but I want to pose a
thought exercise to you guys what if the
roles were reversed and Zack Snyder had
taken over Avengers from Joss Whedon in
2011-2012 how would the Avengers and all
the MC
you have turned out differently with
Zack Snyder behind the wheel
pinch me your theories this I love this
thought exercise Eric and it first it
sounds like oh there's no way this would
have been a good idea right especially
maybe if you're not the biggest fan of
what Zack Snyder has done with the DCE
you but I'm gonna propose that maybe it
could have turned out good
so like in the MCU right the events of
Avengers 1 have had like giant rippling
waves throughout like all of the
properties right especially like you
watch any of the Netflix series right
like all those characters were so
impacted by like the New York event
right like the fight in that first
battle that kind of had a 9/11 esque
impact on the city right and so I think
boy you know who loves 9/11 ask Zack
Snyder Batman V Superman starts with
like the most 911 sequence ever write
and read sequence yes it was and it was
heavy and it's like you know a little
triggering maybe but like you know well
depicted and like created this like
emotional resonance for the rest of that
movie so I think that's what he would
have done like Marvel ended up kind of
like retconning insinuating this anyways
during Avengers
if you've rewatched it recently like you
don't see a lot of civilian casualties
there's the one waitress she survives
right like there's buildings getting
blown up and windows getting smashed but
there's not a lot of blood not a lot of
dead bodies not a lot like crying
motherless children or something like
that
Snyder would have done all of that okay
so then when you know a year later you
watch Jessica Jones season 1 or you know
when Civil War hits and like these
characters are starting to get weighed
down by like the implications of what
they've done right like it would feel
that much more important so I think like
it's a grittier it's a bloodier Avengers
one like you know not that much similar
plot
I do think instead of eating shawarma at
the end they do a CrossFit workout
friendly like knowing Zack Snyder and
his preferences but yes Zack I totally I
totally agree you know and we've been
doing our MC re-watched and one thing
I just can't wrap my mind around is in
civil war in that opening scene with
secretary Ross he's like here are the
casualties of all the things you guys
have done New York the Triskelion of DC
sokovia it's a total of three hundred
casualties it's not even total deaths
it's just casualties it was like
injuries and that's insane to me and the
Tony Stark's all upset about it because
like you know Miriam's like you killed
my son and then like five seconds later
he's recruiting a fifteen year old to go
fight the strongest people on earth so I
agree I think Zack Snyder would would
appreciate the the impact the personal
impact like he would have given us that
moment of when Ben Affleck hugged that
kid and is like where's your mom and she
points up to like the wreckage that was
like heartbreaking and he would've
brought that heartbreak to that what I
think was really missing from them
Souter in that area so for that I will
award you two that has become this
screener of the Martian this screener of
Wonder Woman all released maybe the same
year yes love it all right with movies
I'll go next and this theory is to be
taken with grave seriousness humorous
about the theory I'm about to say it is
simply the way that it would have played
out in this alternate reality no need to
comment no D to anything as we go an
Avengers one of the early moments of the
film is Loki touching the staff to
Hawkeye's heart taking over his mind and
causing him to do bad things for
two-thirds of the movie I believe that
the Snyder influence comes in at the
beginning of the last third when Hawkeye
has a Tony Stark Iron Man list suit off
of him dead to rights with an arrow when
Tony Stark mentions the name Howard cut
to Hawkeye
well you know that day
Oh Howard was my father what his
Hawkeye's father's name Howard in this
iteration I didn't do research to see if
that's true or not that brings him back
from the mind control puts him back on
the side of the Avengers and bonds two
characters that beyond that really had
nothing in common or really any
chemistry of interactions that were you
know no super noteworthy in any of the
subsequent films in Captain America
Civil War we no longer see them against
each other they can't bring themselves
to fight against each other Hawkeye has
to join team Iron Man we see the unity
there at the end
Hawkeye distraught over the death of
Natasha is comforted by his pseudo
brother Iron Man Tony Stark only to lose
him tragically to Thanos I believe what
I'm calling now the Howard connection
will be the crux of the Snyder Marvel
Cinematic Universe I will yield the rest
of my time to the congressman from
Missouri I can never hold political
office in Missouri I can't say the
state's name right I always just say it
like I'm apologizing misery misery Tommy
that's bonkers but I do love it
and you know what we did kind of get a
bit of a mommy issues moment in civil or
right was that remember that was a fun
two-month period from like March to May
of 2016 where we had her our two big
movie franchises had these issue these
two big front men fighting each other
and in the that break into the third act
it was both over like their moms moms
yeah dead moms what a fun time thank you
for taking us back to that and forgiving
hot guys some because I think you are
right something that I think Zach Snyder
would recognize that Jimmy Renner
Hawkeye definitely need some
a little bit of protein at it and they
mention that mention that in this
universe the jeremy renner app has now
exploded it is the marquee social media
app we are all on Renner we're checking
Renner I got in a fight with my
Republican uncle on Renner yesterday
girlfriend she messaged me on Renner
we're getting coffee next week I don't
know my identity was stolen on Renner
just scrolling through bikini photos of
exes I don't know any other social media
i award myself no rookies but i'll
awardee one purple hawkeye oh my god
it's a VHS copy of Free Willy how far
would you go for a friends kind of an
ominous title alright Sam bring us home
with your theory let me land the plane
here gang lay on this bird alright here
we go
so I think it's fair to say that when
Snider went to the DCU the directive
after the dark night was to adapt the
darker popular story is over at DC
Comics like your injustice you kingdom
commie Dark Knight Returns what have you
and for the MCU the original pitch was
adapting the Ultimate Marvel Universe
that was a taking the Marvel characters
the staples the Avengers spider-man
x-men and moving them to a more modern
era and retelling their origins so that
it fit you know we know today what we do
only love about today's political
climate any who's old so I think we're
gonna go ahead and build off that and
we're gonna have the ultimate characters
from the comics be just true to form and
that means everyone's gonna be an a-hole
just through and through everyone's
gonna be a jerk we're talking about
Captain America being a man out of time
in the bad way where he's saying things
that are really politically correct if I
can say it that way I guess it's worse
than that though I know he had some
not-so-great interactions with people
from different races to put it lightly
in the comics but also I would want to
see him say the infamous line when he
was fighting the Chitauri in the comics
he
he points to the a on his head and he
says using this a stands for France and
that's the kind of cap I want to see I
can't believe we didn't even see that in
the movies at all but also like talk
about the other characters I men being
more of a dick as well as Thor actually
pulling like a Superman an ending Loki
right there in Avengers like he already
got past in Thor 1 and you're saying you
took him back to put in prison in
basically a studio apartment in after
the events of Avengers like they kill he
killed it was responsible for the death
of like at least a couple thousand tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
people in that city I think it'd be fair
if you saw Thor do a little with the
Loki or we'll finally maybe see him use
the hammer and smashed his face in but
also it could have been worth adapting
from the original Ultimate Comics the
first big inciting incident that brings
all the Avengers together is the Hulk
going on a rampage and the Hulk and this
is like a monster he's not just a big
hulking scary green dude he's a big grey
culmination of all the bad parts of
Bruce banners personality like he even
like is killing guys were threatening to
kill guys that look at his girlfriend
wrong so I think that's the kind of
stuff we would get from Snyder and a cut
like this and now taking that altogether
I think we get all those cherries all
those little nuggets of goodness from
the Ultimate Comics thrown on the big
screen and we'd all be a little bummed
out being completely honest we know what
we'd still be hard as rocks there you
know because see like those guys a
quarter crew like I made the Civil War
opening actually as realistically bloody
as it probably would be it looked
awesome that's what I imagine like a
Zack Snyder Avengers with B's we would
see real blood there would be heads
rolling people would actually stay dead
which is something that like tends to
not happen in the MCU it's rare that you
have a character die and stay dead I
mean we'll see what happens in phase
four but I'm a feeling we're gonna see
Tony Stark pop up again yeah yeah so Sam
for your pitch I will award you a red
and a blue for not for the French flag
but for the American flag
people in France see movies too and
that's it could be for the Puerto Rican
flag there's a lot of Colombian flag
into a jbo little portable speakers that
you charge your phone with you get taken
to the beach baby I was there all last
week every day
hugging licking kissing volleyball
spiking just getting up in Rochester New
York where it's currently snowing it's
that oh and the second one turned into
the hit Skybound games card game red
flags they'll help you find the perfect
day to your dream by making up bad dates
for your friends all right let's give
these back to me in a tweet please okay
Avengers one Zack Snyder is your friend
like 9/11 let's do it again same tweet
[Laughter]
okay somebody fix the Avengers you
cowards
make it all about Hawkeye Tony Stark and
their father Howard's you could do
hashtag make America France again fight
against the image of cap with the a on
his head with like really bloodshot eyes
but you cap it off with hashtag release
the Whedon cut that's how you breathe
for that one for reminding us no matter
what reality we're living in there are
people who want to see the bad turning
to Shakespearean insult the bandages so
if you want to cover yourself in jokes
that I wouldn't get you can go and use
these okay we've now come the time we
have now come the time
I mean we have now arrived at our final
round of rogue questions ready yes yes
sir
alright question one last week was the
40th anniversary of pac-man what's a
good way to celebrate pac-man besides
playing it okay
this is easy this is what I always do
every year on pac-man's birthday I go to
a graveyard I put a bunch of fruit
around the tombstones and then I scare a
bunch of ghosts into getting up angering
them so they chased me around while I
pick up the fruit and eat it well
normally I would make a maze like a
Halloween maze and you get my nephews to
kind of run through it but you'd have
people dressed up as ghosts aka other
things that really frighten my nephews
and they need to run through it fast as
fast as they possibly can or though
there are fears brought to life
we'll get them I'm a good uncle
those are both super appropriate but how
I choose to celebrate it I mean first up
I'm gonna eat some bananas yeah at some
point and then I take a full-sized photo
of myself I plastered on the wall I just
add a bow on the top of my head and then
I make love to that photo I just
realized something
Pacman's turning 40 then what he's gonna
do to celebrate his divorce miss pac-man
crisis time baby
and like many 40 year old divorced days
there going to be a flat earthers I feel
like the nature of that game the fact
that you can go out one side and come in
the other kind of disproves the
flattered
hey what's none it was an ice wall
portal that teleports you not through
the power of Christ the Denver Airport
were the gateway to hell exists amen
that's right I see that mural that
murals looking creepy man Zach you're
getting the bonus one look it's a
twentieth century women a delightful
family indie film from
okay all right question to guardians the
galaxy star Chris Pratt posted an
instant story this week about how he
accidentally deleted 38,000 unread
emails in his inbox
what email had you sent Chris Pratt that
he never responded to I'm still waiting
on my request to be venmo friends with
him damn it no mine was gonna be the
opposite it was gonna be if I was asking
him to how to turn from star-lord back
into Andy Dwyer yours is better right
mine just says hey Chris Pratt do you
want to increase the size of your
manhood by up to 50 to 75%
well these pills are gonna take you over
the next level baby
[Laughter]
manscaped because size is in the eye of
the pubis the smaller the bush is the
bigger the tree all right and finally
third question Paul Scheer did an
interview this week where he mentioned a
Lucasfilm sanctioned after Darth a
comedic talk show that he hosted playing
Darth Vader as a talk-show host and the
spirit of that show that we will never
see can you do your best Darth Vader
talks to a bit for me okay mine's bad
mine's bad and I'm bad at voices so this
will be really bad I'll say enough to
improve off of what I do so it'll be
something like what's the deal with
Jawas oh so energetically you think the
job was or on Java so this is a
monologue it's a Craig Ferguson task
yeah 9 topical move you need the puppets
yeah okay so this is gonna be the
pro-bowl before it airs so it's after
Darth right it's after dark did I move
on after Darth a Dutch baby was gonna be
thrown some stuff off alleged spit a
little bit sorry
it's like Letterman
and then we get the cut to Darth Vader
just throwing all of his lieutenants off
the building you see droids going over
you see he's going over maybe you see
yeah credo go it over or like Luke
Skywalker you know the famous ones New
Yorkers just stepping in Admiral mati
like take this to the curb all right
arms legs their virginity to Han Solo
what are things lost by the Skywalker's
in the Star Wars saga you had a prop how
did you put that prop together when I
just told you what this question I have
been praying for a Johnny Carson carnet
in 1994 well using his childhood bedroom
for that level of foresight Tommy I word
you that's crazy and it is the VHS of
Free Willy to the adventure home a
wonderful action pack adventure says
Neil Rosen New York one news and then
another psychopath has the balls to say
this is smarter and more endearing than
the original the ideal family movie that
was said by Karen James may she rest in
hell of the New York Times
all right let's view our final scores I
got five I think I also have five and I
have 39 no I know I'm four
she'll be shocked here I come
alright so we have a tie with Zach and
Sam
so our tiebreaker this week will be what
will be the slogan for Justice League
two directed by Zack Snyder okay here's
here's my cuz wasn't it wasn't the first
one was it United the League unite to
seven right so I think this is gonna be
here's your hashtag there's no hashtag
is this logo B we did it and the poster
will be just like Zack Snyder with a
thumbs up start by all those buddies the
buddies of course are batfleck got
Aquaman Wonder Woman flash side work I'm
gonna have to give that win to Oscar
producers a cuddle all right Zack you
are the winner today's episode what is
Jewish that by the way they don't become
a screener of split James McAvoy at his
most physical okay okay well what's my
wish oh I just want to hear everybody's
Martha in their weird filtered batfleck
voice yeah you know every time I pick
you up just once I want to knock on that
door and hear that you didn't say that
name and think ah maybe you made it out
to the west coast Martha it's very good
it was good solid it's inspired
Wow wish granted all right well that's
it for this episode
theory thank you to our guests Tommy
Beck told Sam bachelor and off-screen
producer Zach Huddleston don't forget to
subscribe to the rogue theory podcast
feed and stay tuned to the YouTube
channel for this and other shows follow
us on Twitter at new rock stars follow
me at Ieva
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next week bye bye
[Music]